congressman elect jamal bowman thank you
for coming on the show and
congratulations on your victory
thank you so much it's great to be here
good to see you
are you looking forward to joining a
democratic caucus in the house
in january that already looks split
right down the middle
and where you might end up being seen to
quote aoc
as an enemy by your new house colleagues
looking forward to getting to work you
know my focus is on the needs of
the people in my district uh they
elected me with a mandate to fight for
health care as a human right housing is
a human right fully funding our public
schools
and just doing everything i can to deal
with the issues of today like climate
justice
and the covet dynamics so uh
that's my focus that's where i'm rooted
and uh you know
turn down the noise a little bit and
stay focused on the work ahead
uh well you say turn down the noise
let's talk about the specifics
of the noise abigail spanberg a democrat
of virginia who kicked it all off last
thursday this row in your party
among house democrats uh she was on uh
morning joe this morning continuing her
critique have a listen to what she had
to say
we have specific policies that we've
been for
um and that wasn't that isn't it got
lost in some of the
the slogans that we heard across the
country uh and
and my argument to my colleagues we need
to be far clearer
in what we're for so that people know
what they're voting
for uh and that any sort of doubt and
and to be clear
attacks are going to be lobbed against
us of course all the time
but the more people can say i know what
those folks are for
the more those attacks will just roll
off their backs
does she have a point there about a lack
of clarity in the democrats message
especially house democrats message going
into this election
i think clarity is definitely key
i think being data driven and strategic
to win races is key
and i think us coming together to
organize and maintain
power both inside and outside the house
is also key so this is all part of the
process you know people in groups are
not going to
agree all the time i think the blame
on progressives is completely misbate
misplaced
uh you know people have to run on what's
going on in their district and they have
to respond to the needs of the people in
their district
and as long as we all do that we should
be fine
i'm not worried about a candidate
running hundreds of miles away from me
i'm worried about the needs of the
people in my district that's what i ran
on and that's
why i was able to win and that's why you
know rep elect
spanberger was able to win as well
you mentioned you know your district
versus others districts a lot of your
quote unquote moderate colleagues are
now saying
medicare for all green new deal it works
fine for you or for aoc in safe
democratic seats in new york city
it doesn't work in western pennsylvania
or south florida where your party lost
two representatives
who were accused by the gop of being
socialists
well we have to focus less on the gop
and focus more on the needs of our
constituents
when you look across the country those
who ran on medicare for all
actually won their elections and as we
uh still grapple with the impact of
covid
universal health care a single-payer
health care system
and medicare for all whatever you want
to call it
is something that's very popular and and
most popular
popular um supported by most americans
so again every district is different i'm
not in south florida so i can't speak to
that
um but to blame the progressives uh
is off base uh and coming together as a
party to come up with a clear message
that does meet the needs of all of our
constituents across the country is going
to be critical
and let me also say this progressives
had a heavy hand
in organizing across the country to help
joe biden
win the election ilhan omar specifically
in minnesota
rashida talib specifically specifically
in michigan
yep i organized bus trips of people from
new york to philadelphia
to support what was happening there so
you know progressives are part of the
solution not a part of the problem
so if that's the case then as you say as
you rightly point out the work of
activists on the ground
um the popularity of some of these
policies you say the party needs to come
together it's off base you were saying a
moment ago
to blame progressives why do you think
so many of them are doing it spanberger
lamb
clyburn many many people stepping up to
say
it's the fault of the squad it's the
fault of progressives it's the fault of
the left
what is behind all of this left punching
if i can call it that
i mean i can't speak for them so i will
not
uh try to i think often times when
something doesn't go
a person's way you you default to
uh old beliefs that may be that may be
out of place
or misplaced um but again i just think
um this is the time for us to come
together and figure out how to win
two democratic seats in georgia
that is the key we have to win georgia
so that we could beat mitch mcconnell
so that we can govern so because mitch
mcconnell right now
is not going to let us govern if he's
still the majority leader
so let's focus on winning in georgia
you haven't yet joined the house you
haven't yet actually entered the house
of representatives you're already
sounding very diplomatic jamal bowman
there not wanting to go after your
colleagues interesting
uh let me ask you this about georgia you
mentioned the two seats in georgia
jim clyburn of south carolina who will
be your whip in the house from january
not only said jamie harrison lost the
senate race in south carolina
because of defund the police but he also
says that if democrats
run on socialized medicine his words in
georgia in january
they'll lose those two senate races what
is your message to him what's your
response to the house majority web
you know i think reverend warnock and
john ossoff are going to run on what
they need to run on
to win their elections uh i myself
i'm gonna do everything in my power to
support them in winning their elections
i'm going to work with other
progressives uh and others across the
country
to put all eyes on georgia so that they
can win
um so this is not about speculation uh
this is about boots on the ground
and it's my job to do everything in my
power to leverage my network
to win those two seats that that is most
critical that's all i'm focused on right
now
uh and i look forward to getting started
on that work
you mentioned earlier what happened in
michigan and minnesota and philly
uh do you worry that in georgia where
let's be honest african-americans
especially african
american women helped push biden across
the line in the presidential race
do you worry that that base come january
might want to sit it out because either
a
trump is gone or b they feel like
they're being dumped on
by house democrats who are saying well
they were too woke
they were too far left they were
demanding the impossible
well if they sitted out we have to hold
ourselves
responsible as a democratic party
because it's our job to make sure they
don't sit it out
it's our job to plug in right now
engage listen and get people to the
polls it's our job to register voters
uh between now and the deadline uh to
ensure that we get our numbers up
that we grow the the electorate that we
grow our base
i make sure people come out to the polls
in record numbers i believe on january
5th
so if people sit out that's on us we
have to take responsibility for what
happens in this election
no matter what
we're out of time but one last question
quick question what is the one policy
area the one
issue that you are going to make your
top priority in congress
well there are two answers to that one
stimulus package for covet that's
number one on the agenda two reparations
for the african-american community
enough talk
enough research is time to invest
heavily economically in the community
that has built this country and has been
historically ignored